joey starr bonsoir vous avez en forme la
job quand les gens sont crispés ils ont
arrêté de faire l'amour
je vais me faire masser au bout de trois
questions si tu veux joey starr bonsoir
vous allez en forme comment ça va vous
sentez de prison là si c'est pour des
questions comme ça j'ai autre chose à
[ __ ] sa rivale et donc il est vrai
truc c'est bien moi j'aime bien
d'accidents plus tu auras traduit par
toi même et j'aime bien l'accident ça
veut dire tu vas signer du pip est
conscient de ça chester ça fait
longtemps vous avez pas frappé une
hôtesse de l'air vous prenez le train ou
quoi non ça me manque comment va votre
singe ouais c'était pas le mien c'est
vrai que vous l'avez manger en vrai
en fait en fait chez nous au bénin
et là bas on est homo l'est la viande de
singe avant de la déguster mais dans un
course dans un des autres cultures
spéciales voilà mais c'est bon la viande
de singe ans à la texture du poulet
c'est pas mal hein y'a pas des maladies
abbas qui paraissait pas c'est par le
singe qui est arrivé le sida 1 singer
des congères dès qu'on le fait cuire
un jour je suis allée chez des amis à
moi guyanais j'ai branché
enfin c'était marrant quand il ya des
grands-parents qui est arrivé tak tak et
c'était bien avant l'histoire du sens
j'aurais et genre comme on dit chez nous
ils ont ramené du bon manger tak tak
2000 ont amené des trucs dans de l'alu
il est arrivé la veille
et il faut chauffer un truc ils
l'ouvrent et c'était un singe et on se
servait en fait de la farce à
l'intérieur on servait qu'un la pâte qui
était grillé ce qui était en fait on le
tap pour attendrir la viande alors il
c'est toi voulu qu'il fait l'interview
celui-ci s'est dit tu vois comment je
crois qu'on va changer l'interview je
voyais pas même si on a mal se terminer
parce que tant d'autres interviews
passait mieux je veux bien faire un
meilleur sur les fans car interview de
guy noves
interview guinot joeystarr c'est quoi
votre fleur préférée message
[Applaudissements]
pour vous joeystarr c'est quoi la soirée
idéale à deux chacun songe
la plus romantique que vous aviez fait
dans votre vie bas contrairement à ce
que tout le monde croit
je ne suis au possible donc j'en fais
plein ouais on avait souvent le croisais
qu'un petit bouquet de fleurs bien sûr
que l'on connaît pas mais qui
connaissait bien sûr et je me tiens dans
la bouche en plus
c'est quand la dernière fois qu'une
femme vous a blessé de jouer enfin sens
figuré bien sûr quand on a porté plainte
c'est vexant
cette année deux questions durée 6
interview guillemot 20 ans même biseau
écoute j'ai horreur genre tu étais pour
moi temps si tu deviens tu actives en
plus
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux